what is method writing
oh you're starting off with a hard
question
well i i'm an actor and
method acting is a a big school of
acting that marlon brando and
people like that studied under marilyn
monroe and so forth
and i studied method acting and it
stresses
um an authentic response to what
your work is you're not acting with
gestures you're you're being true you're
being
natural and i was teaching writing
in which i thought i wanted writers not
to worry about the technique or the
style
to begin with but to get in touch with
their
their center their their true voice
so i called it method writing like
method acting method writing
and that was the basic idea method
writing is a
much more complicated methodology of
learning to write
from your deep truth and there are a lot
of other techniques i teach that are
about
cinematic images so in a sense you're
making
a movie in the reader's head so there's
other things you have to know how to do
but the core of it just like with acting
is to be
centered and to be true so method
writing is references method acting
how easy is that for someone does it
do we think that we're being true and in
actuality
we're actually putting on errors and the
audience can see that
and they can see it in our writing well
if it was easy to do that there would be
no uh everybody would be acting
it's not easy to do that that's why
people take acting classes
uh i always ask people what do you learn
what's the first thing you learn to do
in an acting class and the answer is how
not to act
how not to look like you're acting
because
if you've ever been to a play there's
always some some guy that's overacting
and you sense it right away and as soon
as you see the cat
the person acting you're
pulled back from the reality of the
play now of course the play's not real
you know it's a play
but while you're watching it you want to
have the feeling
that it's real matter of fact they
instead of saying you believe it the
theater
expression is you suspend your disbelief
because you know it's not hamlet you
know you know
these are actors but what you what you
want to create
is the feeling of verisimilitude
truth so that the people in the audience
for that hour and a half two hours
can suspend their disbelief and fall
into it
well if you have an actor overacting uh
you know right away that
they're an actor and you can't get into
it um
that's why people study acting to learn
how not to act
to learn how to be natural because it's
very easy to be natural in your home
when you're sitting there smoking a
cigar and drinking a beer
but let's say you beat natural on a
stage with 500 people out there and
you know lights hitting you from above
or in a movie where there's a you know a
camera
looking right at your eye and there's
the guy with the sound boom
and you know 20 people around you let's
see you
relax and be real in that situation
and that takes training now when you get
to writing
people don't realize when they're not
writing authentically
because they they learn to
sound like writers they learn to be
poetic they learn to be eloquent
and they develop a lot of bad habits
in the attempt to look like they're
writers quote unquote
so it's very hard to get people to write
in an authentic way it's hard to get
people to act
in an authentic way but harder to get
them to
write in an authentic way because they
really don't believe
that they are not writing in a natural
voice they
they they have all this fancy junk that
they write
but they think it's oh it's some a
writer
look at me ma but very hard to do that
to get to your natural what i call the
deep voice
that takes focus and it takes practice
and training just like an athlete
you know an athlete's got to be able to
perform with a lot of pressure
and act like there's no no pressure you
know you can't choke
so it's the same with writing you you're
doing something that's unnatural
you know you're right if i were writing
a shopping list
i wouldn't be uptight but all of a
sudden i'm writing my great american
novel my great poem
and you know i'm i'm suddenly going to
be oh i'm a poet
i'm a writer blah blah blah and you
start to push
so it's very hard to let go of that and
just be real and be authentic and it
takes training
is it hard to write a good story
is it hard to write a good story um
no it's not hard to write a good story
it's hard to write a great story and the
only way you're going to write a great
story
is to be willing to write a shitty story
when you try to write a good story
you're in big trouble
just like with acting when you try to be
acting you're in trouble so
again you've got to be calm you've got
to be simple
and if you if you write truly sometimes
you might write a bad story
sometimes you might write a crappy story
but if you're always trying to write a
good story
you'll never write a great story
but if you're willing to fail and write
a bad story or a crappy story
once in a while you get lucky and then
you get a great story
so for me it's like going to the races
i'd rather pick a winner
that's a long shot and makes a lot of
money than
win a lot of little races that pay only
two dollars
so yeah it's easy to write a good story
it's hard to write a great story
you mentioned willingness to fail with
some of your students or others that
you've seen
is there something in them that they're
too rigid and they can't
let go of the idea of being perfect and
doing everything great
or excellent at first pass yeah i mean i
could just quote what you just said
but you see you've got to understand
that as i said it's very easy to be
sitting home in your living room having
a beer and a cigar
and be natural but let's see you'd be
natural in front of an
audience of 500 people or in front of a
the lens of a
of a camera you'd like it a movie and
that lens is you know it's right up
against your face
man you freak out you get nervous you
push you
you overdo it so when you're writing
it's it's a little hard to relax and
just
just be honest be true and get to your
deep voice i have techniques in writing
for how to get to the deep voice i have
a thing called the
transformation line which is a
a certain kind of statement that you as
i say
you massage it it means you take it
deeper and you
you go deeper and deeper into it but
when you're doing that you can't be
thinking of your plot or your story
and again everybody when they start to
write they they first think of a story
they think of what they're going to
write about death
if you know what you're going to write
about before you write about it you're
in trouble
but most people don't want to write
about what they don't know they're going
to write about
because then it might not be good and no
one wants to take that chance so they
start out with
hmm what can i write about oh i know all
right about that time my
my grandfather slipped and fell off the
roof into the fish pond
yeah that'll make a good story and then
they put a little start to write a good
what they think is a good
story instead of just approaching the
writing
from nothing a very zen kind of an idea
you begin with nothing and see where it
wants to go
most people don't want to risk that
because if you do that you might write
something bad
and people don't want to fail
but if you're willing to fail then
sometimes you
you strike it rich can those who are
worried so much about failure
do exercises to lessen that
to make themselves feel either more at
home on the stage
or at home bearing their words to people
that might criticize them
well i do use the term exercises
um in stanislavski who did method acting
he's got the word concepts and
i also was in second city and
did improvisational theater and even
taught
classes in it they use something called
theater games
so if anyone ever watches that tv show
um
[Music]
what's the name of it whose line is it
anyway
they always have a little game they have
to play so
you you have these points of focus
an exercise a theater game a concept
and you learn these concepts and if you
focus on the
concept then you're not focused on the
story
so you can actually practice that but
when you say an exercise to me
every time you write you're doing an
exercise
when i'm in rehearsal for a play and
then opening night comes
i don't suddenly go oh it's opening
night i can act
what you've been rehearsing is not
acting
in the whole six weeks of two weeks
of your rehearsal you're rehearsing to
be true
so when opening night comes you don't
suddenly start acting
you are continuing to do that work so to
me
the exercise is what you do when you are
writing
and if you fail now we go into a
different
issue which is an issue for a lot of
people
who are successful in life with anything
people who are successful in life with
anything
they interpret failure differently
than people who tend to be unsuccessful
when when people tend to be
unsuccessful they interpret failure
as evidence that they're not good at
that
so then they try something else
successful people
whether you're a writer or an insurance
salesman or a banker or whatever
a bank robber you know applies to
everything
when you have learning how to juggle
okay
i'm supposed to drop the ball a hundred
times
i don't drop the ball once and twice and
then i think
well i can't juggle i go yeah that's
that's what happens when you learn how
to do something you fail
so a successful person they interpret
failure as what's supposed to happen
you're supposed to fail and then you
keep doing it and you fail some more
and you fail more or as samuel beckett
said
fail try again
fail again try again fail
better in other words i'm supposed to
fail and when i
fail it means i'm on the road toward
learning how to juggle successfully so
that's the real difference
and the way to prevent failure is to
always aim
for good because ultimately
everybody can be good but to be great
means you have to risk failing and
unless you're willing to risk failing
you won't be great
so when people fail at something they go
oh i guess i'm not good at that
but successful people interpret failure
as
yeah i'm supposed to fail and i'll keep
failing
and eventually i'll get better and i'll
learn how to juggle
and i'll learn how to do it so that's
the key
it's not about failing it's how you
interpret
failure that's the big difference
you